Ein weltraum aufzug der die erde mit dem all verbindet für immer science fiction oder bald schon realität es gibt leute die diese
konzepte für weltraum lifts technologischen heutzutage für umsetzbar halten
Ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht wir übrigens dahin kommt zu whatsapp dass herr vater, am ende
Des videos und bekommt jetzt alle wirklich spannenden facts zum thema
Weltraum auf züge wie weit ist die technik und wo hakt es also herzlich willkommen bei klicks um science-fiction
Seit dem neunzehnten jahrhundert denken die menschen über die idee des
Weltraum lifts nach und erfüllt ganze science fiction drehbücher und literatur und das konzept hat ja wirklich was die erde
Und der weltraum sind verbunden durch einen aufzug der uns menschen aber auch
Fracht mal eben von a nach b und zwar von der erde nach oben bringt ganz und raketen sie wären also eine
preiswerte alternative zur raumfahrt denn jedes kilogramm das mit einer rakete die
Erdanziehung überwinden muss ist teuer der vorteil eines lifts er würde sich eher langsam bewegen dafür aber eine größere menge
transportieren können und dass eben zu einem viel geringeren preis konkret kann man sich das seil des lifts ein wenig vorstellen wie die
kletterseile in der sporthalle der aufzug ist quasi ein geostationärer satelliten der bis zur erde herunter reicht diese satelliten
Sind in ihrer umlaufgeschwindigkeit in einer. Höhe von
36.000 kilometern mit der drehgeschwindigkeit der erde
Synchronisiert sie sind also an einem fixen punkt am himmel in knapp 24 stunden drehen sie sich also einmal mit um die erde
Der experte für dieses thema ist der physiker bradley boards seit 1998 hat er verschiedene arbeiten und bücher zur
Weltraum auf cd veröffentlicht darin suchte nach ideen um probleme wie etwa die stromversorgung, zu lösen
2001 und 2002 veröffentlichte er studien von der nasa unterstützt unter anderem stellt der errechnung an nach denen ein solcher
Weltraum aufzug die kosten von shuttle mission
Um ein vielfaches reduzieren würden zitat wenn man es wirklich wollte könnte man schon in naher zukunft mit dem bau eines
weltraum lifts beginnen das sagt etwas
Er stellt sich den ersten aufzug ins all folgendermaßen vor von einem satelliten lässt man ein etwa
100.000 kilometer langes seil herunter es muss länger sein
Dazu kommen wir gleich auf eine plattform auf der erde da wird es enden ähnlich wie eine ölplattform die schwimmt dadurch würde man das seil
manövrieren können um
Weltraummüll etwa auszuweichen oder die bewegungen des seils auszutarieren das salz würde sich ähnlich verhalten wie bei einem
Hammerwurf es spannt sich aufgrund der drehbewegung des hammerwerfer also, im übertragenen
Der erde weil die hammer kugel also der satellit nach, außen gezogen wird die vision
weltraum aufzüge bei denen man in einer
Höhe von 60 bis 70 tausend kilometern aussteigen kann und zwar auf den mond oder aber man fährt weiter richtung mars oder jupiter das tolle
es gäbe kaum einschränkungen hinsichtlich der größe und des gewichts der fracht draußen
Im weltraum auch die energiekosten während im vergleich
zu raketen kaum erwähnenswert bei allen technischen überlegungen ist tatsächlich das sei die letzte große schwierigkeit ist muss stark genug sein
Wind aushalten und nicht unter dem eigenen gewicht reißen das war bisher immer das größte problem etwas lösung
kohlenstoff nanoröhrchen seiner ansicht nach
Wäre es längst möglich sie in passender länge und menge herzustellen
denn sie sind zum einen extrem leicht und zum anderen extrem reißfest ein farben mit einem durchmesser achtung von nur
0,5 millimeter kann zwei tonnen tragen ein kilometer dieses sei aber wiegt dabei nur 400 gramm wow
doch andere experten
bezweifeln dass denn nur weil man ein potenzielles
ausgangsmaterial gefunden habe sei das laufen längst nicht das endprodukt saal das benötigt wird dennoch gibt es schon einige ernsthafte
interessenten die das konzept in die praxis umsetzen wollen beispielsweise das
Amerikanische unternehmen lift port die vorarbeiten sollen über crowdfunding finanziert werden und der gründer ist sich sicher es ist sehr gut möglich
einen aufzug zum mond zu bauen das komplette projekt würde schätzungen zufolge wohl rund 15 milliarden dollar kosten aber für
Investoren ist das risiko groß wann sind alle studien abgeschlossen
Werden die entsprechenden genehmigungen erteilt dabei ist etwas zur folge der space elevator
tatsächlich die einzig wirkliche alternative zu raketen nicht nur
Weltraumteleskope könnten ins all gebracht werden möglich wäre plötzlich auch der bergbau auf planeten wie dem mars oder jupiter dort gibt es große
vorkommen an seltenen erden aber
Natürlich könnte der aufzug auch uns menschen hoch bringen vielleicht. Wäre er sogar der schlüssel
Um den mars viel einfacher zu besiedeln wenn er als erstes neues zum thema
Weltraum aufzug und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hierbei
Dann erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
Eben vor ab und garantiert ihr können dort direkt in der redaktion von pixum mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen oder
andere vorschläge machen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau wer glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf kriegen 3d druck
revolutioniert die raumfahrt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran